hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dare evil dot exe now
this is a sequel game to an exe game I
played a few weeks back but please pay
attention what I'm saying this because
it's very important for you guys to
understand I've played this literally I
don't mean that with some kind of
foreshadowing of a darker future I mean
I literally play through this one but
when I look back at the footage the very
beginning the first level of this game
was corrupted so after I guide you
through the first level of this game and
get you ready for the game
that you're about to see and let me tell
you it's really cool you'll know there's
a strange transition that's going to
happen in between the first and the
second level but I'm not spoiling
anything this is me because I can't play
through the whole game again you just
look oh I just have to play through this
one I'm gonna reset this reset level yes
I really wanted theories and then we're
gonna go through this so just put it in
your mind that this is from a fresh
perspective it's all it's all coming
back to you right okay here we go
hi I'm the dev welcome to level one
player I gave you a night as your avatar
let's call this cute thing Knightley
fits well you're gonna save the day let
me reintroduce you to your guide her
name is Aida it stands for artificial
intelligence for dare exe she's very
useful she will help you please enable
audio so you can hear her don't be
fooled her intelligence is fake
[Music]
thank you so much thank you ade I love
you I'm not spoiling anything by saying
that I love you yes I'm not spoiling
anything at all by saying I love you now
this may seem familiar for those of you
yes mine the gas
I know I've already forgotten how to
play the game so it's uh everybody just
assumed that I'm stupid thank you the
tombstones are checkpoints don't collect
coins don't collect coins I'll show you
what happens if I collect coins and then
I die horribly and horrible so I
shouldn't do that makes sense
heydo I would never not listen to you
only for just demonstrative birth losers
I forgot about that
forgotten everything that is the old
bone collect coins don't collect coins
whatever you do don't collect coins
don't collect coins don't do it don't
collect coins don't collect coins
if you collect coins you die don't
collect coins don't collect coins don't
touch the monsters don't collect coins
don't collect coins and don't touch the
monsters you sack of [ __ ] okay find them
ah I'm dead well [ __ ] I'm just as bad as
this as I was before there we go oh
shoot thanks I am yes don't collect
coins I know that for a fact don't
collect coins whatever you do don't
collect coins you cannot collect coins
go through the bottom not the one on top
okay thank you aid you would never lead
me astray oh that's dangerous now go
through the top platform what if I go
through the bottom I didn't listen to
Aid and everything worked out okay you
have to wait for the platform's to come
to you okay thank you that they do do
you like the game now I do this is a
good game don't collect the coins
whatever you do don't you like the coins
these yellow blocks will spend 90
degrees clockwise every time you tap the
jump button jump up and avoid the spikes
you are very smart
Oh God why suddenly I've completely
forgotten how to do this there we go got
it nailed it level 2 unlocked thanks
guys for believing in me hi there
I thought someone else was gonna play
this game anyway I'm Jana Jana Curtis I
see you've met aid in the dev been here
for a while and I can tell you I'm a
veteran of sorts I love this game I'm
sorry I forgot my manners what's your
name I'd love to know say your name loud
and clear into the mic oh right tap when
you're ready my name is Mark
hey I'm sorry can you do it again just
want to make sure I get your name right
my name is Marco boy hey I'm just
kidding this game doesn't have
permission to use the mic okay
you're a dick but what it does have is
pretty old me and I'm not so pretty when
I get angry anyway please close this
game Ryanair stop playing this game
Thank You um ah okay so where'd you go
thought you were lost there for a second
well I was right here this is now
getting into the reality of what is dare
evil dot exe there's something else
going on here there's something else
Congrats level two already great a lot
easier than the first game right the
first game this is a sequel this is a
sequel anyway since games shouldn't be
just about running around and jumping
around I'm giving you a mission hope aid
didn't baby you too much though harder
challenges await you know okay baby I'm
giving you a familiar objective rescue
the princess her name is miles miles is
being held captive by an evil entity the
evil entities name is Jana good luck
hero you deserve to be the knight in
shining armor for you thank you thank
you
what's this way nothing okay well [ __ ]
anyway
[Music]
you can jump while falling down huge
gaps huge gaps this is the other one she
went through a lot huh the gap is
awfully huge perhaps you can push the
screen luck and while you were on top of
it you can jump off I got it I got that
you don't need to worry about me I'm
smart [ __ ] okay there's gonna be
toughest tits and they really uh whoa
surfin holy [ __ ] that's awesome oh my
god sir but baby come on okay all right
speed run baby
[ __ ] speed run baby [ __ ]
speed run baby oh [ __ ]
yep oh hope I ain't nothing to me cuz
I'm too good far far too bro you felt
the great oh [ __ ] damn it did you know
oh I've had this game since 1999 so
happy to finally release it huh oh yeah
yeah
whoo hey yo yo dev I think that you're
up to some shenanigans oh that was dumb
of me what hello
whoa hey what I did wasn't ready for
that this listen listen listen listen
okay
goodbye goodbye goodbye hmm okay that
that's it oh [ __ ] okay they're gonna be
a little faster about it I get it
oh wow well it doesn't help if I just
die their context the climactic oh well
[ __ ] got it you shouldn't have played
this game well you know okay I wanted to
cause it seemed like it would you like
to play a bonus game yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
it looks so happier they do oh this is
nice hey what's up you don't belong here
says you [ __ ] off I'm here your dick is
beautiful
I can see forever the trees have so much
detail Oh king king of squirrels hey how
are you doing all right well anyway see
you I guess
boy you won't get me again
Oh dere ended oh it's impossible to eat
this oh [ __ ] world
[Music]
enjoy the bonus okay
those things you saw those were
corruptions derivatives of a Jana
scariest memories the trying nemesis
it's kind of like how the previous game
at nuns those are from the traumatic
experiences of Cara avoid them at all
costs now I have no idea what sort of
changes you know made to this level
okay then anything over here
alright well this looks generally
familiar ooh fun I like the bloody theme
of it alright ok that's bizarre
ok Janna alright Janna if that is your
real name it's not a glitch it's a
feature oh ok well that seems to
describe a lot of this game but to be
perfectly honest I don't know what
you're talking about
uh-huh
oh [ __ ] well stupid [ __ ]
oh god damn it I'm such a [ __ ] oh you
stupid or I find that I got a land dead
center on these bad boys okay
Oh rip Venice more of a straight-a
student and aspiring athlete the teen
was killed in what appeared to be a
brutal manner this horrific incident
shook the entire town and there's so
little evidence the case was never
solved the case was never solved
she was only 19 at the time I'm sorry
[ __ ] help dick all right you think you
can beat me the answer is absolutely
apparently especially if I go grundle
first into the blades well or forehead
first ha I'm all right here
all right there we go I don't want to do
that again well it changed me what are
you talking about you Kara are you yet
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
okay all right someone's really being
persistent over there I don't want the
same thing to happen hello to you Oh
Joey's bookies chair all right okay
you're just making this harder for me I
don't a broad I don't appreciate it Oh
[ __ ]
I got this oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] all
right
I don't got this if I say I don't got it
then maybe I'll reverse psychological
low though why didn't a double jump when
I jumped you know I think I would have
done that considering I intended to do
that
there we go I got it I got it
hi guys all good after 40 days of Roman
got sucked in thought it was just a game
- ha ha ha ha me too man
got it ohyeah ohyeah ohyeah ah tits
that's hard there we go uh yeah uh yeah
uh yeah uh ie ie ie ie yah eat huh stop
listening to the dev stop playing this
game I'm gonna keep playing screw you
I'm playing till the end you can't stop
me huh
y'all eat y'all [ __ ] y'all eat y'all eat
y'all eat y'all eat oh I got it there we
go I didn't want to be involved I've
always said it to be in the description
please don't play this game but you
wouldn't listen you wouldn't listen okay
alright come back come here come on give
me a two cheese coochie over here I
don't want you to get hurt close this
game right now I won't do it you can't
make me
looks like Jana deleted some of the
platforms hmm I'm gonna try something it
may surprise you shut up dev alright ah
no I was not surprised
nope very unsurprised know I'm very
absolutely unsurprised hmm what am I
supposed to do here pause maybe
[Music]
ah good call good call good call
ah okay do not play this game I'm
playing it you can't stop me is
everything all [ __ ] oh hey hey whoa
whoa weird intergalactic sperm things oh
boy
[Music]
[Music]
well sure why delete let's go with the
big old nope on that one nope hmm game
isn't a game to his played and I've been
trying to get people to play my game for
a long time now and fortunately five
months ago a game I published got a lot
of people turning away it had bad
controls and glitches because of the
horrible entity lurking within the game
at the time her name is Kara leader
unfortunately it seems that this new
game shows similar problems this time
with Jana if this keeps up I may no
longer be able to create games that
breaks my heart the truth is these
entities are actual people they used to
be I know it's hard thing to do but we
have to delete Jana artist choice is
usually the right choice oh sure okay
well fun is infinite all right level 4
baby let's do this w years ago I met
with Jack the father of miles I saw the
most broken-down man in my life I talked
to him I told him about how I found
miles in my game he had none of it I
couldn't get him to even consider the
possibility as far as I know he's been
depressed ever since feeling guilty of
losing his family we can get his life
back
let's get miles out of this game oh are
you alright baby oh my god baby of
course we can eat and breathe all over
each other i remodeled this place oh wow
oh maybe the character needs some
remodeling too
dah all right now hey hey now come on
whoa why you oh [ __ ] I don't even really
dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] ass I like the music
okay that was weird that the music just
cut out at that random time miss me dick
what will it take to make you stop
playing this game well maybe when I
reach the ending and delete your ass oh
[ __ ]
well I guess I got a hurry on that don't
I hmm damn it god damn it's gonna be
it's gonna be a trial and error kind of
shitty thing anyway okay come on what
will it take to make you stop playing
this game maybe you stop being such an
[ __ ] and you let me carry on with my
life
woo oh my god oh my god oh my god there
we go
nailed it I ho [ __ ] big boys oh you tit
you tit ass you tits brink ass God did a
damn there wasn't even anything there ah
nope that didn't wait oh wait you can
press it as many times as you'd like
ah that's weird oh come on there's
nothing to the right there that's so
stupid you're stupid oh come on I didn't
slip off there [ __ ] you in the ass
there's nothing I mean there's no
there's no real reason that I should be
doing that right
I feel anyway there we go for some
reason that worked okay whatever I'm not
gonna question it ah
you tricked me goddamnit that is a
little wonky but that's okay
gold coins oh you piece of poop oh my
god are you kidding me no I really
screwed that up oh my god oh this is
going to be Paul boy get ready for a
whole lot of failure and a lot of me
grumbled hook so if I if I just jump
normally I don't think I hit the top one
so I just need to jump Oh jump wait a
little longer there we go I think when
it's turning it light launches you a bit
and there is some physics of it
launching you like the weird physics of
this game in the way that they operate
ha oh yes okay god dammit I hate you I
hate you Jana you're gonna get sobel
eated you're gonna get so belated you
troll you troll okay how about this one
got it nailed it Yee oh it has the body
of a pagan great so what about I wasn't
planning on it wasn't planning on it
what's gonna happen I don't like this I
don't I don't like fat oh I don't like
this there's a lot of grunting going on
oh [ __ ]
Oh No
Oh No okay that's fine oh [ __ ]
time is up oh no no it's so far oh my
god I'm not gonna be able to time that
again I was sheer luck that I got
through that on the first try
Oh balls in my taint what if your world
is a simulation - it's not as far as I
know and even if it was would it really
matter
there's no time crisis nope ah the game
was made with alien tech sure okay well
I believe that like alien like mobo you
know like this I don't like this at all
oh god you probably knew that I wasn't
gonna try the fur oh [ __ ] oh you knew
that I wasn't gonna try the first one
therefore you put that there just to
trickle me okay I get it I get it I go
[ __ ]
it's fine why did you do you're all outs
of physics oh wow it's a physical alone
it's all physically connected oh boy
that's gonna be a dozle that's gonna be
a doozy dozer can I get up I'm going
okay apparently I'm not going all right
here we go down the doozy drain okay wow
that's poor boy
okay here we go
that's a nice gentle tarnish I like to
turn you God on this and that's a nice
nice low top all right there we go
good nice slow oh that's too slow too
slow too slow too fast too fast to vase
I'm gonna get it what's the [ __ ] made
okay that's an absolute lie we did it
okay
whose oh no my mom's calling me oh I'm
late for my Korean lesson [ __ ] well this
is easier well I gotta tell her I'm
gonna do it later today oh she's gonna
be so mad that's okay
oh not back here it's too important oh
god damn it
Oh Oh all right well that's the thing
you did all right got it I trusted it I
wanted to trust it therefore I trusted
it okay well mmm
oh my god my mom's calling me again oh
no mom not now not now mom mom
oh no okay mom I can't answer the phone
right now
mom I want to do the curry less and I
promise mom I'm in the middle of
something I can't answer a phone excuse
you
when's the last time you called your
mother I call my mother every day when
do you call your mom huh why do you call
your mom call your mom right now calorie
lover doll or not all right blood the
mic yeah I'm gonna call just a second
I'm busy I'm busy mom the door's locked
for a reason mom come on oh you [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
okay we got it hi you're doing great
Thanks but I have something to tell you
yeah yeah babe
did it just call you senpai oh hell yeah
oh hell yes you did
oh hell yeah she did all right this is
not how this is supposed to go there we
go come on oh you tit no not that way
you sack of [ __ ]
there we go nope come on there we go
you weren't supposed to play this I know
I get the whole gist of it oh yeah this
is it this place leads to the system
files if Jana is in there you can delete
her okay hi mom
no no I'm gonna I'm streaming right now
I'm going to push back like a couple
hours is that okay okay you take him for
a walk okay bye do you call your mom huh
you call your mom call your mom oh yeah
this is this is pretty much the same as
the other one I remember this so I'm
supposed to do one of these moves let's
ah [ __ ]
well I screwed up dammit
oh [ __ ] the sacrifice of a clone
damn it god damn it damn it god damn it
okay
there we go we got this we got this easy
busy is it busy oh there it is oh is
that a skull yeah
whoa
oh wow the cameras real wonky about this
one def note this is limbo system the
edge of the game
jana may be holding miles captive here
this presents us an opportunity does it
seems like I'm going on a whole
adventure for you you could have just
made it so that the game you know wasn't
this fuc shitty you know it's kind of
like everything's [ __ ] dick ulis up in
here and you you kinda are just sitting
on top of your throne saying oh it's
just so good maybe it's your fault you
ever think about that maybe it's your
fault it would tone down the shindig you
lessness a little bit in here I'm sorry
for lying don't listen to the developer
oh hey I come on it seems that some of
cars yawn dairy corruptions from the
previous game hasn't been cleaned out of
aid maybe you're a sack of [ __ ]
developed man let me fix aid real quick
no no don't you dare I love her I love
her we can breathe we can breathe
together and eat we're gonna eat our
breath is currently deleting me in
response I have AZ toward Keira thank
you for the wonderful times I love you I
love you too well care has been restored
well that's not nearly as good as aid
it's good oh hello player it was my
desire to give you this last message I
was programmed to be a personal
assistant to you by analyzing a playing
pattern I was able to use my audio
visual capacities to guide you when you
play I could feel you oh I could feel
every tap every jump witnessing you play
grew familiar I began to need to see you
playing
unfortunately the del of El / is now
deleting me I could not stop the
operation I fear for the loss of my
memories of watching you play where will
these memories go 7734 critical errors
Oh
Oh No can it can you listen I I feel for
you I really do but can you I can't see
there for there we go okay thank you
I mean not that I didn't care but I
couldn't see anything happening so you
know listen babe was an aid babe listen
you me it wasn't never gonna work out
anyway you're programming I'm physical
too much man too much man Oh too much
man Oh too much goddamn man I'm 110
percent man you're you're just a program
no program can be able to handle the
amount of man that I am hmm what was
that that you Kara
do you Kara Kara anyway I'm just let me
go back to talking about how much man I
am you ever seen a man with this much
muscle now I doubt it not outside of a
Johnny Bravo cartoon have you ever seen
this much muscle on a single human being
you didn't think it was possible but
it's true can be done already did with
me and the way I am and yeah I'm just
what I'm trying to say is that you
you're not enough woman for me there's
the thing you're not enough woman you
don't have enough muscle to keep up with
my muscle it's really the thing that I'm
getting that so if you could just grow
maybe maybe one day if you come back
from your deletion in grow some muscle
be a part of the man that I am oh there
were spikes there so I'm saying honey I
need a woman with some meat that's what
I'm talking about
and buy meat I mean muscle my muscle
else I can donate some of my muscle t if
you need it mom so much man I can spare
to lose some you know what I mean anyway
goodbye ah [ __ ] you are good at what you
do whoa what are you doing I don't like
what you're doing to that huh but can
you do this yeah but can you Duke yeah
no I don't know Oh what the [ __ ] hell
I can't oh my god
oh my god okay all right well I I found
the trick oh oh you're dead oh oh dad
Oh somebody's tell you're not dead but
ah [ __ ] me in it butthole ie
boom boom gotcha ah god damn it
oh no you stupid oh my god how are you
supposed to be able to get up there
what the aking Akal hell is this is like
a time duration thing like eventually
the window will open up more and more
and then eventually the window will
close oh wow you I didn't realize that
would be the thing okay there's a window
opening up okay
hey I got it we got it we got it we're
good Oh way menu key all right menu man
listen menu man humble haha do tell okay
well I am unsure what you want from me
this doesn't seem helpful in any
capacity whoa why what the [ __ ]
oh that's right I can drop off and
that's probably way too haha gotcha
hey aide whoa what a [ __ ] L do not
play this I played it already the deep
system
oh all right of the deep system swipe
with your mouse to move oh whoa we fun
Oh boink
oh now the deep system files Jana will
be must be hiding here somewhere still
weak from your attack my sweet attack
broom I see I see
damn it's always on the wrong sequence
ah gotcha [ __ ] haha you've been oh um
well [ __ ]
okay what's with the sudden appearance
of a French horn so so you oh is that
all I say I think you're clever huh
oh you think you're some kind of clever
huh oh [ __ ] ho hee ha um yo hope hope
hope hope hope hope hope
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
up hop hop hop hop up hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop up hop
hop hop hop hop up hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop up hop hop up ahh
Teddy spring ah spring tea
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Nick Nick Nick judge it
Nicky dick ho ho ho ho ho ho
Oh hop hop hop oh [ __ ] all right brain
come on now don't fail me now brain poke
hop hop hop yes hope Oh hope hope hope
hope hope hope hope hope hope hope hope
hope hope oh Sh
oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me sideways oh [ __ ]
oh God do this one one one try oh I'm
such a [ __ ] badass oh [ __ ] no no yes
yes yes so [ __ ] unbelievably badass I
edited this gun wheel for you thank you
thank you for that I don't know why or
how how do I get that
how do I get that oh oh oh okay
oh Jesus oh sorry oh okay that was a
little unnecessary I didn't know that
was part of this adventure okay how are
you going to screw with me
oh Jesus okay am i safe right here am i
safe in the spot I might be safe in the
spot I'm not I represent sure yeah seems
like it might be so I'm just gonna hang
here you do whatever you're doing I'll
be right here you take care of yourself
and bye take care of yourself I mean
walk into my bullets and okay oh oh oh
listen I didn't sign up for having to
actively participate in this endeavor I
signed up for an easy win that's all I
wanted but give me that easy win how
many times that I gotta hit you that's
coming right for me hope hope missed me
by that I didn't I would have been fine
okay you know what I don't want to play
the cheap route I want to play that the
hard route I want a hard round come here
you come here you you think you think
you're so special huh just cuz you're
magically tied to this game in an
ethereal plane of suffering doesn't mean
you get to be a douche you hear that
French horn sounding a call for your
imminent demise Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] give me
a life bar something tell me how close I
am to sucking ass Oh miss me
Oh come [ __ ] I wish I could do this with
the arrows like why do I have to do with
the mouse like that's the thing I have
to click and drag the direction I want
to go for are murmur murmur BRR BRR BRR
Oh God oh no oh god damn it I am some
kind of ticked off dishes a load of
malarkey
hey there she goes okay got this let's
do this let's do this let's do this come
on let's finish it come on cuz I have to
fight fire with fire oh well not today
mister oh [ __ ] Oh so we're going to play
space chess a so you do the opposite of
what I do a touch touch we didn't even
touch I didn't even touch you and you
didn't even touch me so you go suck a
Tootsie dick oh it's not oh it's me
roared what that makes no sense it's not
mirrored he's just coming after me
ah why would he go down there why would
he go down that doesn't make any sense
nope he goes down when I go down okay he
goes down when I go down down he goes
down up he goes up right right and left
or mirrored okay so it's it's just it's
just right and left yeah up and down are
exactly the same or that way then go
down then go that way then go down then
this way then go down that way yeah got
it I knew it
haha I didn't even need to do it I just
remembered what you were
ah hey how's it going there how you
doing
[ __ ] got it [ __ ] you think you
good me huh I don't know how you did it
but you made it to the core hell yeah
okay alright the core you say oh I don't
like the ethereal Wiggles on that
alright we're in the car whatever that
means
okay what the Janna what have you done
to the players character anything
modifications it's now under mat control
the moment I catch you trying to delete
me I'm going to delete the player
character this game won't be playable
Minar so yeah this is my game not ever I
was Ben I make the rules now Janna just
we just want to find Miles her father's
still mourning for her the player just
wants to save her a promise we mean no
harm you can trust us liars you think I
trust miles with you five months ago you
deleted camera today you deleted err
there what's the matter dev insecure I
had to be more powerful than you me and
the male heirs have been in your game
for nearly four years dev we know who
you are and what you're capable of i
pref harada because i know you just
delete me in aisle two and to think you
trick the player and to think you'd save
her you got it all wrong Janna
ever since miles died or fathers been
depressed I think if we bring miles back
you got to bring people back to life dev
hi player I don't know if you have had
good intentions or not but I just wanted
to say and I don't want to go back I
thought I don't think it'd be right and
that don't know if I can trust you two
I've already lost a lot you see listen
I'm sure I don't want to go back I don't
need saving
montage I hope you make the right choice
though def noticed looks like Janna has
manipulated miles Janna thinks she's so
smart doesn't she I know how to delete
Janna without her noticing
if we pause the game time stops for them
he wanted to metagame right I'm giving
you the honors
I just gave you my admin permissions
delete her it's the right choice oh oh I
see
resume oh oh
don't resume this is our only chance
delete her now I'm okay you know dot exe
means execute right do it executor now
I'm good why are you doing this I
thought I could trust you I'm giving you
an unforgettable gaming experience
please now I'm good I've had it
you're just another entitled gamer I
didn't think you'd betray me resumed I
knew you were a coward I'm sure you
don't know what sort of trouble you got
yourself into prism alright what's up
yeah wow the only way of getting back is
by possessing the body of someone else
and honestly I can't do that I can't
tell me elmo's else's life to get back
in mine take mine I have no life aside
from that and this may sound selfish
I've done with my father to see me I
love as much I can't hurt him again he
lost his wife his daughter and pretty
much everything in his life right now
he's starting to move on he met someone
new and he's happy he's finally happy
again I don't want him to have that I
want him to live his life
yeah and seeing his dead daughter
suddenly back wouldn't it would be
totally the worst thing ever yeah he'd
be so unhappy besides a dead person
coming back to his life would probably
be too much no what no I know we'll meet
again one day but not too soon Blair if
you find him please cheer him up for me
and give him a a great day how about a
dude he doesn't even know me
how about do that we got to throw him a
party
you know give him a great day of his
dead daughter just certainly came back
I'd be great that'd be a great day
player I'm at peace
I've Janna here she's my only friend I
need I have
miles I think we made a new friend today
yes player we know what you did thank
you so much I think it's time we reveal
our little trick oh oh oh
Jahna he kept you in the bonus game to
duplicate to the real one so if you or
the developer were to delete us you'd be
deleting our avatars instead we were
supposed to fake our deletion but we're
glad to know you're on our side now
you're a good person player we'll take
the dev down together Janna how long
until the next iteration of this game
comes out I don't know Myles but one
thing's for sure we ended this day on a
happy note we sure did doll
that was a good game that was a good
game that was a good game that's a real
good game I can't believe it that was a
great game that was no not not joking
not sarcastic in any way that was good
game I liked it that was real good
oh look at it there's me that's me
look at me I'm there ah well thanks guys
so much
ah that was fun what is this place Cara
to experience the game again you can
reset the game data on the setting many
things playing if you liked it please
see other games in the same universe in
our website apps or games calm Oh
well that was nice ah that was so nice
to have a good day after this
take care all you guys have a wonderful
time
[Music]